if you're looking for ways to ignore the
critics being driven and strive for
perfection then this video is for you
you can't be scared to push the envelope
you shouldn't never know nobody put you
in a box and just tell you you're just
this you know I'm saying that's all
you're gonna ever be this crazy but a
reliever who the strongest and I'm
saying who last long I'll just drop the
perfection on and off the court okay so
I take what I do very says the
motivation watch your top ten with
believe nation what's up at seven my one
word is believe and I believe in you I
believe you have an amazing gift inside
you that I want to see explode out onto
the world so let's get your motivation
to attend and get you believing in you
grab a snack and chew on today's lessons
from a man who had a self-described
empty childhood to becoming a rapper and
collaborating with Usher on love in this
club that shot him to number one on the
Billboard Top 100
he's Jeezy and here's my take on his top
ten rules of success enjoy
let's kick it off with rule number one
my personal favorite
push the envelope you were bred to be a
businessman like you know your legacy
and just in and I tell myself that all
the time my legacy just can't be great
records right I can't be who I am
forever I can't just be you know just a
guy that made some great songs like what
am I gonna do you know why I'm here what
kind of market am I gonna leave when I'm
not here to people who say you know what
he really you know did this thing and
it's like you can't be scared to push
the envelope you shouldn't never know
nobody put you in the box and just tell
you you're just this you know I'm saying
that's all you're gonna ever be this
crazy you know I look at people like
Magic Johnson I'm not a great ballplayer
but look he's a greater businessman you
look at Lionel Richie yeah he was a
great artist but he owns half of Rodeo
it's for real you know me and that's
real life and everybody knows it it's
public record so at the end of the day
you should never let nobody just put you
in the box because they feel like you're
doing one thing great why can't I do ten
things great you know saying what can I
do twenty things like why do I have to
stop at one thing because you feel like
that's who I that's who and what I am
I'm still building and learning and
pushing myself every day so it's never
gonna style mistake creating goals and
I'ma stay achieving them i'ma stay
executing I'm gonna keep my team you
know just on on deck so they can
understand my vision and to see why I
want to go because the sky's the limit
you could do anything you want in this
world like anything if you want to do it
have you always felt this way absolutely
when I jumped off the porch that's what
it was about you know when I got off the
porch I didn't all my family worked in
factories and had these little you know
lose little jobs but it was you know
there was content and my whole thing was
I were never gonna be content like how
could that happen how could you tell me
that I have to stay here in this one
place and me and my mother living this
small trailer forever it's like not my
mother have a nice house I want my
sister to go to college I want to put
myself in a better position so I could
do things I want to one day you know
wake up and be able to sit on the beach
all day - yeah if I see you know Bill
Gates anybody else do this it's like
everybody has their beginnings and their
stories but it's not at the end of the
day if you let people just put you in a
box then you already lost you know I
mean I'm not gonna stay if you're not
gonna stay hunger is just like what
you doing a helps if you're not gonna
more information you know every day if
you're not gonna push yourself every day
like why are you here for like you're
wasting your time you're wasting the
people around you times it's like it
might seem to tell you right now today
we can hit all type of success what's
next what are we doing next
oh this is what I want to do yeah rule
number two is hustle as a kid when you
were starting out like I know you know
they had a lemonade stand if did you
start off having a business as a kid I
used to cut grass man I just pushed my
lawnmower around early you know 10 11
years old
extra old ladies can I cut the grass you
know anyone from that to me standing on
the corner by the house but they still
was cool with you know that's how men
come out you know give me food Sunday
you know me I come eat we'll go back on
the block I never told nobody this is
something that we do in Georgia like
doing the summers kids we used to go
throw watermelons without our elders
nice [ __ ] the watermelon my uncle you
get big brush snakes anything that's
growing these big-ass fields you throw
watermelons and whatever that load is it
might give you twenty thirty dollars for
that day you've been in the Sun all day
at the end of the week I might have you
know $100 but $100 and ones with a 20 on
top look like a lot I should just fool
all my friends like you don't get money
you know me and it was like damn G zero
out of like we making the money you make
you know meaning we getting paid crumbs
but always run natural-born hustling
rule number three keep pushing a wins a
win like no matter I warn when I got out
of it
I went when I got you know my first my
first opportunity to get in the booth I
want when I got my first show you know I
warned when I got my first cause I've
been getting my own name I want when I
brought my mom first house you know
saying what my grind and not doing
nothing illegal just with my passion and
all the things I was going through you
don't say I want already then so just
sit right here it's kicking ice cream
you know I'm saying you can't beat me at
my game that's the playing that's what
Cena knowledge about was about anybody
is going through anything man keep your
head up in your chest down and keep
pushing on these [ __ ] [ __ ] man they
can't beat you though you guess all you
cannot lose trust me I'm not
you can't lose you stay you and stay
true
man just keep pushing rule number four
listen more I have no regrets you know
especially being why met as a black man
so that's that's for you know first and
foremost but I think it's been times
that I wish I would have listened you
know to myself and and and others when I
felt like I knew what I was doing yeah
so you know I've learned to listen more
than I talk yeah I mean so that's it the
best advice I could get anybody and not
being scared to better yourself and and
that's you know why I always want it
ya know we're losers drunk I'm gonna
learn something you know I mean so I
don't really have any regrets but at the
same time I could tell you if people are
giving you information you know sit back
and listen to it digest it you know I
mean just think about how the
information can help you because you
know idea could be life-changing man
yeah it's change your whole life and
everybody around you yeah you have to
treat it like that you can't just go
into it like I know everything you know
and when I was coming out of the streets
I figure you know I beat the streets I
got beat anything but now oh this is
business
this is real life you know if you don't
handle things right you know you you
might not really get back where you were
right rule number five be driven so
professor Jeezy there's another alias
that we could go by now
urban philosopher yeah so if we're gonna
give someone a diploma or a university
degree yeah what would you call it the
school of hard knocks man you know in a
reliever whoo too strong this you know
I'm says who last loans everybody goes
through different phases to success but
how long are you successful how long you
gonna keep that drive you got to keep it
cuz the minute you wake up and you go
you know what I'm tired I can't do it no
more
no rule number six stay true to yourself
I don't just put out just to save it
I've done it oh you know I hit up the
thing I'll townie put out you know said
says put out five mixtapes now I'm with
you like dannis little for them you know
I'm saying like cuz I ain't here to
compete come the people who can compete
with me I just competed with the best
person that could be with me that's
jay-z
who else is it way to come to what I do
you know I'm saying so and I hear my own
I've been on tour with Jay and they tie
up my own so you know when the music is
gone and you know and the music is gone
and there's no more magazine covers and
I who are you I'm gonna be Jeezy hey hey
I ain't gonna be nobody else but me my
albums have been so successful because I
stayed true to me if it takes two years
to do man who gives a if it's right when
they get it they're gonna love it rule
number seven get knowledge information
is so crucial people have no idea that's
to me more valuable than money of course
that's just like especially after being
in a game for so long and you've
experienced the ups and downs and the
ropes like that that game you could give
somebody it's just knowledge it's just
like you know it you know it from any
athlete to any you know just any book
writer to you know anything that you've
done or gonna do is always somebody who
went through it before you yeah actually
you know when you get in the road they
could tell you look you know you might
want to try this or you might want to
try that and that's you know for me
that's what my music has always been
about it's not sharing the information
yes you know so it's just like I'm not
here to you know
wow you're amused you I'm here to say
look when this happened to me ya know I
took this route you know that might not
be the route you want to take but at the
same time here's the information yeah
this is what I achieve you know that
might you might want to achieve more you
might want to see less that's on you but
you know let's just be fair about it he
is rule number eight find a way to
express yourself I grew up in a trailer
my first trend is I bought my mom a 13
years old one even big at this role you
feel saying I couldn't fit a [ __ ] right
right and I couldn't even fit a bed in
there bro you feel sad like you know so
they just let you know when said you
don't say my mom looks great now you
know saying my family is grandpa Munster
sister to school I did all these things
for these people because I had passion I
had drive right
I had integrity I had all the things
that matter you know it's a humility
like that ain't wrapped
I'm here for that y'all people and why
because at the end of the day that's my
way to that's my way to share my message
you know figure if I'm saying that's why
that's why you have somebody that goes
it becomes a preacher it's like you know
they might have had their pass they
might have been through things but they
learn from the experiences that's the
way they spread network you know say
this is the way for me to look out for
my people and continue to be Who I am
and use myself and the things I learned
as a gift to others rule number nine
always give your all I'll treat my
mixtapes like albums if I go in I do a
mixtape I work on it just like it's out
like everyday ignite grind and I listen
to it I ain't on myself sit then I put
it out you know to hold them off because
that's how I was feeling at that point
of time before me so like now with this
album it's like you know I had to get to
that point where I feel like okay all
the records they told this story cuz I
didn't want to just put it out to meet a
quota you know it ain't about money with
me this ain't about no money
it's ain't about no famous ain't about
no man this is about real nice this is
about you know just keeping it silent
with yourself and knowing that you put
your all into this and all these records
help to you know to tell the story you
want to be told it's like sometimes some
of the records don't fit you got to go
back in and they ain't about me being
around not a rapper I'm not to do it's
gonna going in just make a record and be
like okay this is jamming it's for the
club is put it out it's like not on the
body of work I want you listen it is
you'll get some gems out of you're gonna
have something to live and die by you're
gonna feel it you know I'm saying but at
the same time ten years from now it's
gonna be that same feeling annual number
ten the last one before the poni says
strive for perfection what is a goal of
yours that you are still working on
you're not going to stop at each um just
being on Connie you know being you know
forever and I think the way you do that
is you just don't let up you just go
hard every time but today get it comes
in and once they get it they got it you
know just just I just strive for
perfection on and off the court okay I'm
saying so I take what I do very
seriously so you know even my personal
life you know means I treated the same
because you know handle myself the same
way on and off court you know me so
asbestos how rock
you
now I've got some special GZ bonus clips
for you but before getting to those my
question of the day today is are you up
perfectionist and do you think that's a
good thing or not leave in the comments
below I'm excited to hear from you thank
you guys so much for watching I believe
in you I hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one where it
is
much love I'll see you soon and enjoy
the bonuses
if I tell you uh you know Thug
Motivation that's about you know
motivating some people that I think that
have been demonized or put in positions
where they can't be successful it's like
not it could be successful you know you
might have to go through a couple things
but you know it is a way around it just
loop but like with you know your lawyer
tell you there's loopholes and
everything so you know and like one of
my friends told me you know it there's
there's a crime behind every success
story you know I'm saying like but at
the same time you can clean up you know
what it is you're doing and open up
doors for other people by your trials
and tribulations through your words in
your music through your just showing up
in a detention center for kids in
Detroit man you know you touching people
you were able to confine for you and
yours and you're comfortable with doing
that and you got a mixed mood planned
and you're successful you know if your
wife is at least some type of chicken
she's cool with that and y'all Billy I
got a roof over your head your kids
don't want anything you got
transportation to and fro and
everybody's cool with you can do things
you want to do in between you know it
might be small things could be big thing
[Music]
if you had to think of one word that's
most important to you or that sums you
Apple that would be like a little beacon
they believe nation if you want to know
what the most important one word is for
Tony Robbins Gary Vaynerchuk Oprah
Winfrey will.i.am and Howard Schultz I
have a very special secret video for you
check the description for details
[Music]